[Musique]
bien sûr pour vous distraire vous ouvrez
le bottin téléphonique de paris tome 2 à
la page 2 sans 3 vous ne trouverez
aucune mention de la société magic k1
sans dire que la société magic à
n'existe pas non la société magica
existe écoutez son histoire
parent brumeux soir d'hiver de leurs
1883 deux passants se croisèrent devant
plus dé grise et leur destin soudain
changé ils s'arrêtèrent et aperçurent
disposés sur les marches quatre petits
paniers contenant chacun des des juifs
au même instant la même idée ils
échangèrent leurs cartes dire tiens
tiens comme c'est la variable et
quelques jours plus tard associé le bébé
grandir très vite les deux jules père
adoptif découvrir émerveillé que les
adolescents avaient adam très rare le
génie de l'invention leur imagination
était si féconde que bien souvent une
découverte à peine fait il que les
chercheurs encore à quoi cette invention
pourrait bien servir ce point de vue il
était très en avance sur leur temps
grâce à ses quatre inventeurs la maison
magique à chaque jeune avec un neveu
cinquante ans plus tard les deux
directeur fondateur transmirent leur
pouvoir leur 9e john et james thiery
terreau naturellement des quatre
chercheurs
aujourd'hui johnny jane sowden tabac
banquet en l'honneur de gaston faber le
plus ancien représentant de la maison
[Musique]
vous
on
beau
[Musique]
ans
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
voilà
à la santé de magicka à la santé de
magicka à la santé de magicka à magiques
a écrit l'une est tellement dû à la
chanter de marie cardon enfin la bonne
santé de la jcch arabe amazighe
[Musique]
alors là mon cher ami permet souvent je
voudrais adresser mes compliments à vous
vos collègues petite merveille et moi je
vous dis par deux je vous dis bravo
c'est tout à fait ce plan b c'est une
initiative communale
ils ont l'air très content une fois les
locaux accompli m'enfin faut savoir
attendre fin berakha renfort pourvu que
ça dure
l'homme est dit de faber vous avez
entendu qu'est ce qui s'est passé pas
bien
je ne sais pas j'ai entendu comme un
gémissement vous avez entendu damas
mais était-ce connaît de qui se moque
t-on ici ils devraient compte en tout
une bonne idée n'est pas l'humour qui
les détournent
mais mon pauvre marseille le colloque
atteindre et vous l'âge adulte georges
adultes
aucune en or jamais onésime à votre
santé quand tu y mange du porc il avale
épine dorsale
[Rires]
là
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai trouvé notre homme ah
oui vraiment vous l'avez trouvé ma mère
croit qu'il a trouvé son homme pour j'ai
trouvé je crois notre homme vous avez
prouvé vraiment où étaient nos toute
façon c'est fichu ça ne marchera pas en
troisième en partant de l'extrême droite
je vois pas ce qui n'est pas un peu
jeune et un peu trop réservé un sondage
que j'étais aussi jeune et aussi réservé
à
messieurs mes chers amis nous nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour fêter là
nous qui après quarante ans de
représentations réintègre ce jour la
maison mère j'ai nommé notre ami sa
belle
vous connaissez tous babel et pourtant
je pose la question qui est il savait je
pourrais vous dire que monsieur faber
est notre plus ancien représentant 7
je pourrais vous dire que monsieur faber
est un collaborateur fidèle
c'est vrai je pourrais vous dire aussi
que faber & magic a sont liés intimement
indissolublement par les doigts c'est
vrai aussi mais ce n'est pas suffisant
pour dire quel homme est monsieur faber
car avant tout voyez vous comprenez moi
et après tout monsieur faber est un
phénomène et oui oui un phénomène et je
m'excite
vous avez toujours été mon cher chabert
le représentant de points celui qui
toujours à réaliser les plus gros
chiffres d'affaires qui vieillit crise
patrice déflation ou d'inflation
surproduction ou pénurie vous votiez
toujours sans arrêt par tous même par
internet
je veux dire par intermédiaire je dirais
même parce que c'est mal et je dirais
même c'est un éloge que si on vous
l'avait demandé vous auriez vendu
l'invendable mais quel est donc votre
secret
[Applaudissements]
ap
mais pour m
vous avez essayé de nous le transmettre
en écrivant ce petit livre vous vous
relatez toute l'expérience accumulée
depuis tant d'années pour en faire
profiter nos jeunes représentants qui
reprennent le flambeau en leur nom au
nom de tous ces jeunes que vous allez
maintenant conseiller et diriger je vous
dis merci merci et encore merci
[Applaudissements]
merci messieurs les directeurs
merci mes amis ce jour pour moi est un
grand jour mais je vais vous faire un
aveu je ne détient aucun secret c'est
vrai j'ai l'expérience mais qu'est ce
que l'expérience dans notre métier sinon
être aller coûte de l'humain sinon
comprendre les autres hommes deviner
leur motivation est retrouvé en chacun
lâche t il y à quelques 40 ans un jeune
homme j'ai sonner à une porte de coeur
battant le bal du siée et sans doute
pour se débarrasser de moi on achetait
ce que j'en ferais sur l'instant je n'ai
pas compris la raison de ma réussite
c'était pourtant bien simple j'avais
souris et bien toutes les situations que
j'ai rencontrés sont contenues dans ce
petit livre que vous avez eu la
gentillesse de me réclamer bercy il ya
deux mois qu'ils ont préparé leur dire
moi je le trouvais pas mal c'est idiot
il sait pas pourquoi il parle moi je
sais pas ce que c'est c'est eh c'est
grâce à nous sans nous ils oui oui sans
nous les inventeurs il n'y aurait pas
que sa fille était magique car à toi
toujours toujours avant boite on faire
le plein la drève la drave à chaque fois
qu'on a volé j'étais ça contre 3,2 me
serait il donc j'ai observé petit gars
je lui ai aussi en béotie vous avez
raison c'est peut-être un oiseau rare
alors je combats
vous dites vous
n'oubliez pas que nous sommes les seuls
intellectuelle de la société mal rica a
savouré bourg et la tête d'arabe ramé g
il n'est personne qui ne désirent
acheter
il faut diriger ce désir vers l'objet ou
la chose que l'on 20 ce premier pas un
conflit
le vendeur ne suscitait le besoin de
l'objet et imposer sa nécessité
alors petit gars 1 en forme mais
monsieur enfin à peu près il faut
toujours être sûr de soi ou tout au
moins elle faire croire aubry oui
monsieur
on va vous recevoir tous dessus
petit garage vous pouvez enlever
[Musique]
asseyez-vous petit gars
vous avez prouvé votre place
un petit grain sur le conseil de
monsieur faber nous vous avons choisi
pour une expérience de vente transmet
auprès d'une clientèle
interrogés lors d'une enquête
préliminaire
nous plaçons notre confiance en vous
l'objet à vendre et notre dernière le
deck use le dk eu des cas pour réaliser
l'importance de la tâche que l'on vous
confie petit gars oui monsieur tout
notre campagne de publicité sera basé
sur les rapports que vous nous en verrez
deux parades x il s'agit de millions de
francs petit car fort réussi je ferai
tout pour le dk use esseulé directeur
vous prendrai contact avec notre
département de recherche
nos quatre chercheurs vous expliqueront
oui monsieur monsieur faber et n'oubliez
pas petit gars c'est sur mon conseil que
vous avez été choisi je compte sur vous
vous devez réussir et pour cela
soyez un autre moi même
compris
oui monsieur abel
[Musique]
où
bon
[Musique]
on
cette musique le clou
[Musique]
non
où
mais monsieur sujet
[Musique]
il est monsieur monsieur si vous voulez
lire et je m'appelle petit garage oui je
viens pour le dk musée messieurs
[Musique]
c'est mes cigares
oui ça l'est libyen pour vendre notre
des cas use d'un ciel est bas ils
feraient mieux de le donner comme normal
n'écoutez pas ce petit à rien entendre
rien de ce qu'il fait n'est wanda mais
c'est un maniaque l'est et les jouets
tapis naceur regarder ce qu'il fait una
soeur elle cloue de son invention le
cloud wiwa et une girafe le court ac oui
c'est mal fait à les dévots messieurs
nous avons beaucoup de travail et pas de
temps à perdre à les pincer
enfin c'est suivi le nam messieurs la
poutre ou du moins de mains de
l'événement
le jeu voici le teckel bonne petite tête
devant de petits gains regarder venez
boire c'est extraordinaire ça me plaît
oui je vraiment ce ce extraordinaire on
va vous montrer voilà à honorer voilà
voilà voilà
permettez de monter ça bouge oui vous
avez compris de ce qu'est ce que c'est
ça la et rouleau à pâtisserie légal est
pour bientôt
alors toi c'est ce qu'elle fait oui
c'est moi qui l'inventé maréchal ferrant
mais n'anticipons à auch et pour enfants
qui ont mal aux dents voilà
hadwin et de santé voltaire à tadla
alter bien équilibré donc quand même des
haltères c'est très compliqué parce
qu'on est blé pain ça m'a gêné lui il a
vu les plans oui voilà voilà
alors tu rosen attention si le pauvre
antennes de la première scène
la vente est bon la seconde chaîne et
les plaques ondes pour la couleur à
l'unisson couleurs voilà c'est la
douleur mais ma vie qu après servir
aussi de serre les coudes alors la dia
les gros c'est pas un canon et magna il
est maniaque tu es un enfant pas de
renault saïbi ses confrères est alors
partie baissa petit gars à carmaux
rentrez chez-vous vie hors des bassins
timide dans la d'imitateur été choisi
c'est pas ma bulle et moi je vais faire
vos deux thématiques la cubain manuel
dont tu pas mal à nommer on peut noter
un débat papen canne à pêche assez
solide pour la croissance du passif
voilà et alors là bon groupe en
attendait donc je ne sais pas si j'ai
appris c'est je crois qu'on doit
pourquoi si seulement tu t'y prends
toujours travaillé dans le mois alors ça
on le retourne mais attention comme ça
vous avez une béquille bourget en géant
avant de voir le bout que vous avez la
démonstration d'une béquille doral grâce
à cette pratique alors au le jour où
vous revenez de faire ce que nous
disions alors à celle de bougeoirs
blatter c'est là d'ailleurs vous n'avez
tout le débat mais comprendra ce week
end à nancy comprendra mieux les
télégraphistes aux instruments modernes
pour faire la quête alors ils vont me
prépare je me plais vraiment faire la
caisse serait le tombeau de très récents
petit groupe a pas de petite manon aux
abonnés
non on l'arrêté ça vous allez voir t c
est l écoute de maga ça ne tombe pas la
monnaie la presse que par lui il veut
parler cost regard la petite je n'ai pas
encore commencé pas
et voilà maintenant à tampa tama très
long trop là qu'est ce que tu vois
l'amiral nelson vous voyez là vous avez
un batteur et on va tout ce qu'on veut
l'année alors qu'est ce que tu as eu
beau crier mais bondit de la balle
six mois par titre en dit vous suivez
oui 15 faits des noms mais bien moins 15
d'entre eux prenaient il avait la toile
de pierre mais sur une cheminée qui
s'apprête jeunes audois petit tableau
bien voulu honorer des yoyos d'une radio
bien vouloir lui l'amour bien sûr
lipow alors petit diarra vous l'avez
compris question m'a dit un jour qu'on
avait souvent besoin non non c'est toi
alors sur l'arena il va pas interrompre
alors que ces garages vous avez vu
quelques exemples des bons alors petit
gars n'ont pu y sont parlées vous prenez
cette balise
toutes les autres sont déjà dans le
coffre de 23 points de plus aux
messieurs nous avons perdu à 7 ans aime
ça allait mais n'y en aura pas
ferme la louer une casserole
pour moi vous savez la valise et
beaucoup beaucoup trop lourd mais bonne
chance quand même
[Musique]
où
le foie
[Musique]
tous
oh
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
[Musique]
même pas cucul
où
[Musique]
merci j'ai crevé ah bon voulez vous bien
parce que je joue j'ai pas de route
mangeait pas de chrétiens aussi si vous
allez au village vous pourriez peut-être
demander qu'on vient de me dépanner et
puis quoi encore
les avons pas non je vous dis de
m'excuser c'est pas ma faute je vous dis
j'ai crevé mais je vous assure j'ai pas
pu m'arrêter quoi
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
quelqu'un et quelqu'un je suppose que
vous avez retenir une chambre oui le
leader par téléphone avant un claudine
claudine ont subi un bris de monsieur
vous avez retenu une chambre oui hier
par téléphone
c'est voir je m'appelle petit garage je
suis désolé d'arriver si tard mais j'ai
eu un petit accident sur la route
oui j'ai crevé à et si vous savez
pourquoi
et pourquoi à cause d'un fer à cheval
vraiment donc faire un choix et vous
pour travaux nerfs et en plus je n'avais
même pas de criques aux eaux il vous en
arrive des choses
bon comme au dégoût petit gars petit
grain
nous avons beaucoup de monde à ce moment
une équipe de rugby au yoyo je ne veux
rien à ces normes sepa prochaine non je
vous assure on m'a téléphoné hier pour
réserver vous rêviez servent un trou
ah oui c'est ça ouais ouais ouais je
remplace à bière alors vous devez
sûrement voir l'église comme monsieur
vous venez souvent ici c'est un monsieur
d'un certain âge s'avère un peu
corpulente nueva eu c'est ça oui oui je
vois je vois mais ça y est la maison
magie car c'est cela même effacer at
elle dit oui oui mais ça ne va pas être
facile à attraper eux au pardon à vendre
je voulais bien de moi où je vais bon eh
bien si la chambre 31,51 très bien vous
voulez monter tout de suite au non non
non je préfère dîner d'abord si ses
cachets je crois qu'il vous reste encore
une petite place mais alors une toute
petite alerte est pour mes bagages non
ne vous inquiétez pas je m'en occupe
travers c'est la porte au fond non non
là bas au fond
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
alors
garnir les gradins se parle il fait un
temps mais merci je prendrais vous
convient je ne sais pas si honnêtement
que ce que vous avez des escalopes
seulement ce cas là et vous prendrez
yves hervé d'après comme me suis pas dit
non mais dites moi vous avez une
excellente mémoire où les clients
réguliers j'ai un petit carnet sur
lequel je n'osais pas
un des cantons partenaires heureusement
les développeurs de pièces l ai pensé à
un prix très bas
alors
m
la victoire de l'équipe de france tous
les joueurs
oh oui
non
[Applaudissements]
je suis sportif arrivée elle a été
embauchée après
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ban
bush aux hôpitaux situés à l'entrée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur je vous êtes gentils
avec moi pour passer la route de
championnat oui je comptais la jeune
homme ou de celle ci a bien dormi
ah oui ça vous étonne jours aura été
[Musique]
avéré que monsieur état sportif dites
moi qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça
messi a résisté aux plaquages résister
c'est beaucoup dire engagé
j'ai plutôt subi je me sens plein de
cambouis est-ce que je dois encore
beurrer un nombre encore une j'adorais
confettis mois valait beaucoup de face
et être un bon match de coupe de monde
dans le jeu de nouveau tout faire sans
lumière bleue avant les gérants de fonds
n'ont même pas encore dit mais pas à la
wii je comprends vous passez des
calsades un nom maintenant avant un le
banc oui mais je vais aller m'occuper
des autres clients me disent moi de
perdre beaucoup de temps si vous arborez
à tous les partis n'ont même bonnes
ventes est la vrai gentil m
bonne journée pour bourg et ses enfants
pour les pertes et les travaux qui a
fait quoi
on voit encore aux curieux
premier client est très important
paradixxx voilà
poulard fortune 1 8 rue des oiseaux
paradixxx fonctionnaire retraité d'un
commerce très agréable
[Musique]
non
aum
où
[Musique]
m
ce jour là encore je suis bien au 8 rue
des oiseaux
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas bon
parce que vous avez peut-être m'a
enseigné mais je cherche un certain
monsieur poulard fortuna qui doit
habiter le 8 rue des oiseaux pour
monsieur poulard troisième à droite
autrement dit c'est 8
[Musique]
au françois monti fonds soit au mont
dieu mon dieu c'est à janvier encore
qu'il aurait vu ton oncle de fortuna qui
est revenue petit même beau au monde
garde son vrai nom oui oui il aurait
même pu lire ton télégramme
il a voulu que torture se fasse dans ces
circonstances mais la rondelle est en
jeu monsieur et à nuire des mesures de
vous ben oui
ou bien si mal géré merci mais regarde
qui est la france doit donc le fortuna
maintenant parler toi mais tu me
reconnais pas je suis catherine gâteries
la cause n 4 et 4 non ne parle pas c'est
trop d'émotions tient vraiment petit max
bois non françois que je n'ai pas vu
depuis quinze ans mais mon garçon c'est
long 15 à 18 ans bresse le
oui mon français
voilà c'est fait
[Musique]
non
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai joué des tours pendables à
l'emploi 31 me raconter la scène paraît
plus cramé
je premiers mois
célestin l'emporté j'avais dû serrer le
frein à main de la voiture
oui j'ai été un affreux jojos la chine a
raconté sa g quelle affreuse aujourd'hui
gâteau mais écoute toi tu as bien sûr
j'ai touché depuis je dois dire que tu
es un si bon petit gars qui sait si
gentil d'être c'est normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
bah
[Musique]
ils nous voient d'en haut même s'il n'y
croyait bien il faut maintenant que je
parte aux différentes lois qui ne pas
pas nous laisser comme ça tu viens à la
maison chez nous
je viens avec nous à la main
non
alors mon petit françois parlez nous un
peu de toi bien si longtemps que tu es
parti avec ta chère maman
quand will france par acomptes
raconte-nous l'australie puis
l'australie l'australie
[Rires]
[Musique]
coût
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jeudi qu'a eu en main le petit livre de
faber vendre pour vendre en poche
henri petit gars 1 part confiant pour sa
première vente premier client la mire
échec il à sa grande surprise on le
prend pour le cousin françois venu
spécialement du bout du monde pour les
funérailles
[Musique]
on
fois timidité soit 6 délité au principe
de saber petit gars n'osent pas démenti
[Musique]
et d'un bon petit france toi tu en as vu
des choses et ainsi ces oiseaux comment
tu les appelles les émeut les émeut oui
eh ben ils se nourrissent de pierre
c'est pas croyable mais non voyons
m'attendent il avala cailloux ce temps
en temps mais ils mangent aussi autre
chose un petit cigare mais il faut que
je vous dise quelque chose je ne suis
pas je sais pourquoi tu n'es par nicolas
mais non c'est pas ça c'est pas depuis
ce matin je pensais que je ne sais plus
je ne sais pas ce que je ferais je n'en
peux plus moi tu es trop fatigué tu as
besoin de te reposer
ce sont quand même de drôles d'oiseaux
cme c'est pas croyable ou non françois à
skis et toi j'ai préparé patients dans
ce jeu vous allonger davantage comment
l'économie de toute façon j'ai obtenu ma
chambre d'hôtel de francs mais monde qui
est carrément passé sinon je ne veux pas
briser puis de toute façon déjà
j'attends des communications de jean
d'australie en tout cas tu sais que tu
es ici chez toi hein tu reviendras oui
écoute mais dis moi en ce moment en
australie
il fait jour le matin quelle famille mon
petit garçon au revoir et huget revient
vite nous voir un revient très vite
c'est promis ces produits quinze minutes
oui ton manteau qu'un mon jeu surtout
temps qu il fait un choix et vous tissez
quiton qui gardent bien sûr à bientôt
küffer mais du point d'y arrêter on voit
qu'on n'est pas là vanilla n'oublie pas
sur tout mais bien sûr là il tu reviens
bientôt monde et porte toi bien fort
voire mort va vous a fait un tel plaisir
8 août attendant mieux attendons
à bientôt bientôt tu prends le maire oui
merci
je
monsieur
mais monsieur arrêtez vous arrêter vous
quoi piquer ce cas c'est évident qu'on
lutte vous de temps en temps oui je
cours vite pas vous êtes sportif bon
excusez moi je vous servant à traiter
comme ça mais j'ai complètement perdu je
cherche l'hôtel de france à l'hôtel de
france et du tribunal réuni oui oui oui
oui oui vous allez tout droit
vous arrivez à un carrefour vous prenez
la grande avenue sur la gauche vous
marcher pendant un kilomètre environ
jusqu'à un fleuron qui ne fonctionne pas
la nuit d'ailleurs là vous prenez à
droite et ensuite la deuxième sur la
gauche vous marchez dix bonnes minutes
et vous arrivez à l'hôtel c'est bien
compris je vous remercie
bon pourquoi vous me direz merci tout à
l'heure pour l'instant répéter pour voir
quand vous irez vt alors je vais tout
droit oui c'est ça fait j'arrivais un
carrefour a bien servi le carrefour je
prends aussi comme hier 1er ensuite la
première droite
non non non non non le troisième à
droite noyant la troisième à droite et
et puis j'arrive à un autre carrefour
n'avait rien compris mon pauvre ami vous
allez tout droit
vous arrivez à un carrefour
[Musique]
pur produit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
bien joué aux roses richement
la société magical les pouces
[Musique]
et on
première je repasserai
vous
[Musique]
johann jacquot
c'est amusant magica
[Musique]
au moment n'est pas là bon c'est bien
voir
[Musique]
donc
ce jour là
je suis bien chez suraud d'euros
mais c'est de la part de la société
magica
je ne suis pas la peine d'être mal élevé
on voit là
[Musique]
non
où
[Musique]
on
que c'est bon d'une beauté aïd à arriver
mais oui c'est ça vous l'avez dit et
tout ça ce vice ah oui oui bien sûr et
puis ça se dévissent aussi évidemment ça
doit valoir une fortune ah bah non en
annonçant valls enfants et en plus vous
pouvez acheter à crédit
oh non je paie toujours content et 10 et
pour les jeunes aux ailes
vous allez avoir une bien jolie robe etc
c'est pour bientôt le mariage demeure et
bien permettez moi de vous féliciter et
mademoiselle voit la jeune homme 10 11
12 qui s'axe israël mais c'est moi qui
vous remercie madame je dois dire que
vous êtes là clients très bon
bon maintenant il faut que je vous
quitte pour m'occuper de mademoiselle
mais je vous en prie madame renée un
cigare très volontiers qu'ils ne s'y
attendait pas ces deux là je suis à vous
dans une minute
[Musique]
bien nous y sommes non je voudrais
mettre quelque chose de gros comme ça
qu'est ce que c'est je me demande je
pourrais peut-être mettre salah et bah
non je vais c'est qu'il est là comme ça
nous à la fois l'appareil extraordinaire
pour faire quelque chose mais quoi je
n'en sais rien sympa si je m'étais non
ça ne marche pas tellement bien de rien
on ne voit rien du tout j'aurais bien
voulu faire ça mais je crois je ne
pourrais pas alors j'ai fait autre chose
[Rires]
bonjour mon amante
excusez moi de vous déranger je
représente la société magic
je ne sais pas monsieur justement je
suis venu pour vous informer vous avez
je ne sais pas moi je ne suis pas
intéressé mais c'est certain nombre vous
êtes certainement intéresser puisque
vous figurer sur la liste
vous êtes viendrait mme leclerc ah non
non non alors vous ne vous n'êtes pas
main parce que excusez moi mais qu'est
ce que c'est c'est pourquoi
eh bien je représente le dk use à sa non
alors
[Musique]
madame matin le oui je représente la
société magic a lors d'une visite
précédente de loi ordinaire à signaler
que vous seriez vivement intéressé par
une de nos dernières fabrication j'ai
dit ça en moi certainement puisque vous
figurer sur la liste et alors
et bien justement je suis venu vous
présenter notre nouveau né le dk use on
ne m'a jamais parlé de ça mais pourtant
je vous assure comment vous appelez
votre machin le dk use
je vais même vous montrer si vous le
permettez on ne vous dérangez pas c'est
encore un coup de césar césar c'est mon
mari si je l'écoutais on achetait tout
celui mantoue heureusement que je suis
là moi et je veille au revoir monsieur
[Musique]
général lankais oui bonjour général je
représente la société magica et je suis
venu vous présenter notre dernière
invention utile
je ne jette jamais rien et un conseil
jeune homme
la puiser jamais de la confiance des
awards
[Musique]
il
allô allô ici petit gars compte rendu de
paradixxx dont sûrement de mauvaises
nouvelles armes et tes doigts d'en turet
peut toujours là mais il est 3 37 libye
silence devant les graves c'est-à-dire
une réussite inférieur à 3%
à quoi attribuer cet échec relatif il
apparaît tout d'abord que le vocable des
cas usées peut-être trop exotique pour
l'oreille moyenne de notre clientèle
pour les clients se sentent un peu
perdus
enfin tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ça ne marche pas très fort
[Musique]
non
et bien d'après les premiers sondages ne
peut pas dire que c'est un succès fou
mais ça il faut reconnaître qu'on peut
pas parler de succès mais il faut
reconnaître aussi que c'est sur votre
conseil que nous avons choisi petit gars
1 et ça c'est grave mais c'est très
grave
et puisqu'on ne peut pas parler de
succès c'est qu'il ya un risque d'échec
ce qui pose un problème
nous sommes tous d'accord pour
reconnaître qu'un problème se pose n'est
ce pas mais vous êtes drôle
tout dépend comment on pose le problème
nous allons nous y perdre si nous
étudions le problème par rapport au
problème
une chose est sûre les gens ont besoin
du déca use
il aspire tôt déclaré lise ça ne passait
sur comment ni pourquoi on leur plus
améliorée vous mettez trois dont on a la
tête comme ça où le dic a usé hors de
question de son don soit l'acheteur soit
le vendeur qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
oui ça paraît évident qu'en pensez vous
monsieur le directeur
qu'en pensez-vous faber je crois que
c'est clair oui c'est clair
nous devons donc réfléchir pour trouver
une solution une solution
il faudrait peut-être éduquer la
clientèle au jeudi poteo et leur payer
des cours du soir aussi voyez pas
corrosives ou solution les condamnant
n'oubliez pas que nous avons investi de
grosses sommes dans cette affaire il
faut donc trouver une solution à ce
problème une solution à ce problème une
solution à ce problème ans a fait 3-2
solution à ce problème une solution à ce
problème une une solution
crois que j'ai unis
gimbert a pu éviter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aum
[Musique]
c'est ça oui puisque certains d'entre
vous met en question les aptitudes de
petits car 1 il faut lui envoyer
quelqu'un pour l'aider le contrôler mais
il est indispensable qu'ils ne se
sentent pas surveillé et surtout qu'il
ne crois pas qu'on doute de ses
capacités à l'eau je propose cette
solution oui très vain notre
représentant aux états unis arrive à la
fin de la semaine pour un séjour de deux
mois
oui il va suivre petits grains sous
prétexte de prendre contact avec la
clientèle française
c'est une excellente idée c'est pas une
mauvaise idée
il nous semble mais quoi qu'il faudrait
l'améliorer ah oui messieurs c'est vrai
à condition de l'améliorer
oui c'est assez pas une mauvaise idée
encore une fois il faut qu'on en discute
une question de couverture voilà pas
beaucoup moins quand ils font leurs
messes basses ou pas soit il faut
reconnaître qu'ils ont parfois de
grandes idées petit gars 1 ne connais
pas brevin alors nous avons réfléchi
puisque ces brèves hacker doit aider
petit gars il faut que ce soit un faux
brevin voilà comment ça explique les
vous formerez 20 mai un vrai faber
expliquer non bien sûr nous expliquons
si vous préférez un vrai faber mais
disait en vrai vin puisque vous
seulement gère pas vers une collègue
sont d'accord là dessus vous êtes le
seul qui puisse y ait redressé la
situation qui pose un problème ne
l'oublions pas les l'oublions jamais or
comme vous ne voulez pas y aller vous
même sous le prétexte fallacieux que
votre présence traumatiserait petit
gamin je vois aussi c'est pas sérieux
petit quart à me reconnaître
mais le déguisement ne pose aucun
problème et du desus et non les aider
juste en toujours bizarre et saugrenues
l'important ce qu'elle soit juste voilà
alors confiez nous votre tête nous
allons la remodeler croyez moi vous
rajeunir et de 10,0 doivent modifier
les oreilles aa le lob de portland pas
oui mais on va vous faire refaire le nez
il faudrait qu'il retrouve son sourire
qui vous a permis de gagner votre
première affaire oui nous allons vous
retirer la peau du tout pour que vous
soyez bruit et ont pris mais on pourrait
lui plus planté dessine pas pourquoi il
retrouve le regard de mme suu kyi
souvenez-vous rythme haletant oreilles
de velours ifa verte royer les hommes
croyaient nom de robert libre dames lipp
à bord sont assez tentant
et à l'usagé est ce que tout ça tiendra
tiendra salle navarre nous dit on
connaît ses capacités
c'est qu'avec tout toutes ces
modifications je vais plus pouvoir me
retire les alors un conseil un bond au
torino la voyez les voies mer croyez-le
oui eh bien je veux bien vous croire
alors
ap ap la wii c'est sûr que quand on
mettra quand si on l'enlève home et vous
serez nature on sera ellis tout est
alors la diminuer tout remontrer relais
oh la la
ici et là on pousse très beau il est
déjà bon train
ym bascule dans la beauté n'est pas un
point sûr il ya les télégrammes pour
vous en dire de la porter
c'est grave non non ça je sais pas je
comprends pas pourquoi monsieur paul si
je pouvais me permettre ce que voulez
vous quand parise et enfin si j'osais
qu'est ce qui va avec joe diop
j'aimerais si ça ne vous dérangez pas un
livre dense et la barque que voix vous
montriez ce à quoi ça ah ça va le dk use
édifices et bien je vais vous le montrer
et bien voilà comme c'est curieux mais
ça sert à quoi
petit gars on va vous montrer enfin
commencer un concert mais non nous
enquête le prouve et 9 femmes sur dix
attendent avec impatience bien qu'ils
ignorent de pouvoir enfin posséder leur
deck amusé mais bien sûr bricoleurs ou
non intellectuelle ou manuelle membres
des professions libérales
même les commerçants et ouvriers
commencent à un ouvrier
mais bien sûr un ouvrier vous avez bien
que les ouvriers sont très intéressés
par tout ce qui est nouveau et c'est le
dk us suscite l'intérêt unanimes il
intéresse tous les hommes et les femmes
comme aimait bien sûr le fameux enfin 99
femmes sur son son rêve a inconsciemment
de posséder enfin elle aussi un jour
leur des cahiers moi mais vous tenez
vous bien sur vous n'êtes pas pourquoi
tenez par exemple le fait de la couture
doux nom oui ça m'a un petit peu quand
même si une fin d'un petit peu de
couture et bien vous allez voir par
exemple ya une chose à laquelle on ne
pense jamais c'est très désagréable
d'avoir se blesser sans arrêt pour
amasser les épingles et bien avec cet
objet là vous n'aurez qu'à faire ça
regardez vous en avez votre impact sur
instantanément ramasser vous n'aurez
même pas vous baissez wipolo par exemple
est ce que vous avez l'habitude dont je
vois des amis chez vous à la maison soit
il ya une chose que je trouve très
agréable
ces deux dîners le soin aux chandelles
ça c'est formidable
eh bien regardez ça voyez vous n'aurez
qu'à faire ça comme ça c'est très bien
vous prendrez ceux ci et ceux ci et vous
aurez de quoi vous aurez un bougeoir
allons maintenant si vous avez une
grande déception le choix moi je vous
conseille non pas le bougeoir tout
simple mais ceux-ci qui y est vous allez
devinez tout de suite vous allez me dire
vous même
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un camp d la
brand là alors là regardez c'est très
joli n'est ce pas si vous avez une
grande c'est joli non
alors maintenant est-ce que vous avez
besoin de la télévision non moi je
voudrais bien mais vous n'avez pas la
télévision
enfin vous l'aurez un jour sûrement
chacun aura sa télévision eh bien
lorsque vous aurez votre télévision vous
aurez déjà une chose à la maison avant
même d'avoir eu votre télévision vous
aurez quoi vous aurez votre antenne et
voudrait pas seulement votre antenne
première chaîne vous aurez regardez là
dedans passez moi le petit modèle
vous allez voir vous aurez non seulement
je disais 20 30 à une première chaîne
seconde chaîne mais vous aurez quoi vous
aurez votre antenne m'étais ceci à
chaque extrémité là bas je vais faire la
même chose ici vous aurez votre chaîne
coup l'air c'est pas mesdames non
regarder les jolies an plus tôt
elle est extraordinaire maintenant ceci
dit est ce que vous avez l'habitude vous
faites un peu de cuisine de la maison
oui bien sûr alors vous allez voir je
suis sûr que vous n'avez pas de rouleaux
à quoi vous aimez les gâteaux et bien
avec ça vous ferait de la partie serait
un rouleau à pâtisserie est
extraordinaire maintenant est-ce que
vous avez une bicyclette
oui vous avez une bicyclette je suis
persuadé que vous avez perdu votre pompe
sur votre bicyclette
comment vous avez à mais moi je sais
tout eh bien regardez vous aurez une
pompe à vis maintenant
tenez vous allez faire une petite chose
avec moi vous allez m'aider vous allez
construire avec moi le déclic
vous savez que des journées des familles
je dis bien des familles ont passé des
journées entières à découvrir les
possibilités infinies du dk bus parce
qu'elles sont vraiment infimes
alors vous allez faire ça avec moi vous
allez vie c'est comme ceci n'est ce pas
septembre ses quatre petits objets là
dessus voilà pendant ce temps là moi je
vais vous montrer autre chose mais ça va
faire du bien à vous allez voir mais
c'est une surprise
il ya beaucoup de surprises avec le
décalage avec ceux ci comme cela voilà
et maintenant je vais est ce que vous
avez l'habitude de vous faire des
shampoings la maison des shampooings
alors ya une chose qui est très
désagréable c'est d'avoir se sécher les
cheveux comme ça avec vous servez dépens
de l'ès pas alors là moi je vous propose
n'est ce pas un séchoir 1c soir
j'aimerais bien vite elle attend les
secondes voilà comme ceci voilà je vous
propose un séchoir h
alors là c'est formidable en seul but un
peu sont séchées cinq ans plus tard
voilà alors vous avez fini votre petit
travail
vous allez me le passé voilà attendait
deux secondes je vais les faire style
cette pièce voilà alors là moi j'adore
une chose j'adore une chose moi ce sont
les mayonnaises comme ça les choses
alors avec ça en 30 secondes avec son
mix up vous aurez vous aurez une
mayonnaise formidable fantastique
attendait voilà fabien lemoine stéphane
fodé moussa lisant les biens est
formidable en même temps ceci dit vous
avez là vous êtes un objet
extraordinaire vous allez me regarder
avec ça regardez moi bien que ça un
regard de la mairie mois regardez-moi
d'intro un truc comme ça qu'est ce que
c'est c'est un kaléidoscope qu'est ce
que vous voyez
bah oui quoi sûrement ça intéresserait
antoine qui se sentent même s'est montée
à ses plus bas de france hier à toutes
mes félicitations et c'est pour bientôt
le mariage à la fin de la saison
à la fin de saison ses toiles assez cher
le comment vous là pour le des cailloux
aux excuses moi il faut que
fonctionnement que j'aille à la gare
j'ai rendez-vous le dégage maintenant
maintenant se fâche r 125 et en plus
vous pouvez lâché à crédit c'est à dire
que vous versiez tout de suite 45 francs
et alors vous savez je crois
cinq ou six titres est oui de 15 francs
à peu près je voudrais bien l'acheter
mais un crime mais bien sûr écouter on
fera ça tout à l'heure je vous ferais
signer tous les papiers et alors dites
moi une chose c'est un cadeau
extraordinaire pour antoine savoir
vous
au mr bazin big apple
[Musique]
excusez moi monsieur je fais peut-être
erreur n'êtes vous pas monsieur petit
gars c'est vraiment exactement je suis
très heureux de faire votre connaissance
moi même monsieur vous avez fait un bon
voyage pas mal merci j'ai pu écouter
nous allons aller tout à 29 ans avec
plaisir il ya quelques bonnes petites
spécialités sélectionnant les jets de
beauté votre valise et 13 m
oui c'est très agréable
toutes les gares c'est très beau mais
avait eu un petit peu de mains ok je te
donne droit qu'à fait très bien les
choses
l'accusée une française un contact bien
voyez vous vous voyez quelque chose m
l'hôtel entier
j'étais très bon à part fait vraiment
alors on n'était pas limité par le temps
c'est pas grave c'est que à bas coût des
loyers ou j'hésite le boeuf aux motardes
à la ficelle traiter ça me mais comment
succomber merveilleux cassoulet ce sont
2 de spécialité mais me donnez moi un
cassoulet c'est pas grave on est sûr non
pour moi simplement un fromage
je suis si heureux de passer mes
vacances en france
et quel beau décor c'est charmant ici
m'a donné un petit appétit tout faux ah
oui si vous disiez aux états unis vous
ce qu'on veut rien comme moi la cuisine
et mamans mauvaise inexistante
or c'est triste d'ailleurs de voir grand
pays privé de grande cuisine véritable
tragédie mais la clientèle américaine
doit présenter certaine singularité
elle est tellement conditionnés par la
publicité qu'elle doit elle est
terriblement logique oui elle obéit à la
loi des grands nombres
oui on avait ce titre sûrement publicité
et on attend les gens viennent de même
vous manger dans la main est un grand
pays tu as voilà mon cassoulet il le
donne à quelqu'un quand même effet peu
[Musique]
et le le travail d'un représentant la
barre en amérique complexes ont très
complexe et ou à ses dépens l'an passé
qu'à paris et la province en amérique il
n'y a pas de paris seulement la province
un grand p provincial que désirez-vous
comprendra un petit peu de gruyère
annonce enfin un peu de commentaires
on est bien moi vous mettra un petit
assortiment belle place aux donc servir
aux nouvelles comme des siennes une
banane flambée simplement
et vous non mais sérieux à café c'est
parti je vais vous poser des questions
au sujet de ma venue ou robin la raison
est très simple
j'étais curieux de comparer votre
clientèle française à notre clientèle
américaine aux méthodes de vente d'
approche de la clientèle enfin je suis
venu ici pour apprendre pour m'instruire
tout vous dire que je suis soulagé parce
qu'il faut que je vous dise qu au départ
lorsque j'ai reçu un télégramme de la
maison magical j'ai d'abord pensé quand
même envoyé quelqu'un parce que parce
qu'on n'était pas très content de moi
je sais très bien que le dk usées très
important pour magicka mais il faut
avouer que les premiers jours de vente
n'ont pas été très brillant - comment
cela alors oui j'ai été tout de suite
mais hier une histoire invraisemblable
voilà alors j'allais visiter mon premier
client me suis un certain monsieur
poulat fonctionnaires alors j'arrive
chez lui bien il était mort alors je
vous assure alors sa nièce me saute au
cou
oui m'appelle françois françois poulard
merci d'être venu me dit elle sa tante
aussi enfin je me trouve mêlé à cette
histoire semblable
je n'ose pas alors expliqué que je ne
suis pas franchement plus là
l'enterrement va une chose et l'autre
je ne sais pas je partais dans cette
histoire est la cousine
comment est-elle alors la cousine a
l'air très joli petit grain vous êtes un
grand malheur car ce sont les risques de
notre métier parfois ce sont des risques
agréable savez j'en ai pas beaucoup
confie t elle
alors on était plutôt la victime une
victime consentante maintenant voilà
maintenant pas du tout pas du tout non
plus
maintenant elle semble même mon adresse
à l'automne on verra bien et combien de
dca eu
vous avez vendu
buts
évidemment j'ai pas beaucoup c'est pas
beaucoup
vous avez enfin je crois que je suis sûr
que le des cailloux ça doit marcher mais
la clientèle n'est pas encore habitué
comment dire c'est un objet attendu et
en même temps inattendus comme on est ce
que je veux vous montrer bien écoutez
moi je suis venu ici pour maje et oui
mais si je puis vous donner un jeu
offrira enfin vous êtes très gentil
écoute étonné si vous voulez 7 à mably
vous pourriez peut-être ma campagne mais
très beau et je me sens très en forme
j'attends ma banane et nous y allons
parfaitement à la voile à la à
on n'ose pas y toucher
m
pas chômé mois avait complicité
je suis par les 4000 calories vous savez
je crois que c'est par là oui c'est je
vais regarder sur mon petit grain de 12
oui alors le 12 oui c'est ça nicolas
l'enfant alors d'après le carnet c'est
un homme affable imbriquant leur lait
sans professeurs mais c'est intéressant
de voir une idée du client comme ça
avant de l'avoir vu
oui d'ailleurs c'est une idée de
monsieur fabre est intelligent ya ça m'a
coûté une balle et vous en arrive nous
avons l'air d'être attendu entre
messieurs je suis heureux de vous
accueillir
c'est nous qui sommes heureux de vous
rendre visite pour ainsi tout est
parfait comptez vous en prie
je vous en prie messieurs et dames
or on voit tout de suite que vous êtes
un voleur
j'avais de très bons outils très
perfectionnés c'est typique et bien il
nous reste à vous dire le but de notre
visite nous sommes des représentants de
commerce et nous sommes venus vous
présenter dans cette valise un objet qui
sera certainement digne de figurer dans
votre collection
j'aurai le croire aussi vous savez
j'étais au courant de votre visite vous
voyez prospection a été bien faite et
bien il s'agit du déca use le club si
vous voulez le tube des tubes à essai
l'amusant le roi du tube
excusez moi un instant je dois
téléphoner oui c'est drôle non
comment pouvait-il être au courant dans
notre visite quelle importance
ils vous attendent et c'est l'essentiel
mais quelque chose touché le maire web
et ils sont venus ils sont là ils se
présentent comme des voyageurs de
commerce
c'est une clé sans surveiller d'accord à
12 juin bien sûr ils ont leurs raisons
vous prendrez vous même livraison du pub
d'accord
d'accord je leur communique le rendez
vous je leur dirai au revoir mais si je
vous dis parfait j'ai des amis qui sont
intéressés par lisant le tube et qu'ils
seraient très heureux de vous rencontrer
vous êtes très agréable c'est la moindre
des choses
le rendez vous est fixé à 5 heures au
bar de l'étoile laisser dans le centre
nous y serons et maintenant si vous le
permettez je vais vous montrer notre
dernière fabrication fait je vais vous
brise un intéressement
notre bureau d'études s'est attaché à
créer un objet qui puisse offrir de
multiples avantages
simplement parce qu'il peut être utilisé
à de multiples usages
on naît l'idée est très simple cet objet
le voici voilà pourra vous servir tour à
tour deux ventilateurs d'aspirateurs de
ses cheveux d'antenne de télévision de
candélabres etc
mais l'important je dis bien l'important
est qu'il peut servir à des usages qui
restent encore à découvrir
très ingénieux
et très simple le dernier cri de la
technique et vous serez surpris quand je
vous dirais qu'ils ne coûtent que 125
francs je suis en effet surpris ici
qu'on nous accuse de faire du tome pic
comme le japonais
les japonais je vois vous le vendez
vraiment oui si vous avez 125 amusant et
astucieux a oublié quelque chose là vous
avez un catalogue et vous verrez à la
fin de ce côté là que vous avez des
pages blanches qui vous serviront à
inscrire les nouveaux usages lorsque
vous nous a découvert je vois bien plus
fort merci et n'oubliez pas à 5 heures
au bar de l'étoile la technique compter
sur l'homme c'est notre intérêt bien
compris messieurs j'ai été enchanté de
faire votre connaissance se prévalent
donc je vous en prie au revoir messieurs
ils viennent de partir à l'instant
[Musique]
excusez moi s'il vous plaît oui un dry
pour monsieur
mises d'accord voilà messieurs quelque
chose
zeste mes côtés
voilà
en
c'est quand même que nos abonnés
[Musique]
très sympathique monsieur l'enfant peu
bizarre
vous savez les bricoleurs sont toujours
un peu poète mais il est très coopératif
moins ça pour votre copain du pays
[Musique]
je dois vous conduire votre on n'a pas
vu venir c'est que nous allons notre
voiture nous vous accompagnerons combien
mon coup droit
voilà monsieur doucement cinq ans
toussaint quand un dixième de décaler
nous sans attendre pour voir monsieur
[Musique]
dépêchez-vous le patronat à temps voilà
pour vous
[Musique]
rapport à celui d'un logement créée par
les clients comme ça tous les jours
j'avais nous avons convaincu on n'a pas
peur mais non encore accompagnera fait
des meubles à vous
le
[Musique]
je
il
les amis au diable les amis de monsieur
l'enfant
monsieur et
monsieur l'enfant nous a fixé ce
rendez-vous à kiev le rappeler mois
jérémy amelin monsieur jérémie justement
monsieur l'enfant nous a taxés sans
doute exact
[Musique]
bien avant payet
on y arrive
[Musique]
vous
où
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça y est ils sont là avec la valise
bon point le tube dans leur salle
[Musique]
on appelle tonné le continuer mais je
vais vous faire une démonstration et le
tulle le patron connaît que les
raccompagne
[Musique]